with Energy prices soaring in the year
since the invasion of Ukraine government
support has been Central to cushioning
the impact on households the energy
price guarantee effectively caps annual
household bills for typical usage at
around two and a half thousand pounds
now from next month bills were due to
increase to 3 000 pounds but Sky News
understands Chancellor Jeremy Hunt is
now expected to extend that support two
and a half thousand pounds until June
sparing households a 500 pound increase
so let's look at how we got here since
2019 energy bills have been controlled
by a price cap set by the regulator off
Gem and think of this line as the real
cost of supplying energy you can see
prices were capped around a thousand
pounds but by April last year the cap
had reached 2 000 pounds and in October
it Rose above three and a half thousand
then higher still above four thousand in
January before falling back a bit this
spring so in October the government
introduced the energy price guarantee
capping prices at two and a half
thousand pounds we know this planned
increased to three thousand pounds isn't
happening and ministers are hoping that
by the spring on these forecasts the off
gem cap will fall below two and a half
thousand pounds and government
guarantees can be withdrawn now the
actual cost to government is this red
area here that's the difference between
the price guarantee and the real price
to energy suppliers and that's less than
expected and this is why wholesale gas
prices have fallen sharply they're still
around double the pre-war average for a
couple of decades but they're well short
of the peaks of the middle of last year
and this is why the chancellor feels he
can afford to extend support the initial
forecast for all this was around 42
billion pounds but the actual cost so
far is just short of 27 billion with the
three-month extension costing around 2.6
billion the total less than 30 billion
pounds and it's worth saying as well as
supporting households this spending
should also help inflation full now this
doesn't mean the government has more
money just as it has spent less than it
expected but the clearest Ben
beneficiary is the consumer and hundreds
of thousands of households that may now
avoid being dragged into fuel poverty